[Musik]
herzlich willkommen aus Köln schön dass
Sie dabei sind bröckelt unser Wohlstand
jetzt noch schneller wir haben in den
letzten zwei Jahren erlebt wie die
Inflation Ersparnisse auffrisst wie
steigende Preise dazu führen dass ich
viele Menschen vieles nicht mehr leisten
können und diese Woche nun diese
Nachricht die Volkswirtschaft der
Bundesrepublik soll die einzige sein
unter den großen Volkswirtschaften die
in diesem Jahr schrumpft überall sonst
Wachstum Bundeskanzler stolz strahlt
ungerührt Zuversicht aus seine
Koalitionäre haben unterschiedliche
Ideen wie man mit Milliardenbeträgen der
Wirtschaft helfen kann
Oppositionsführer März hat ganz konkret
ein großes Konjunktur und
Strukturprogramm vorgeschlagen unser
Thema heute Wirtschaftsflaute wird
Deutschland abgehängt und ich freue mich
auf diese Gäste Rudolf Heckel ist bei
uns mit Herausgeber der Blätter für
deutsche und internationale Politik
Wirtschaft Wissenschaftler und seit
vielen Jahren Gast in dieser Runde ich
freue mich auf Roman pletter er leitet
das Ressort Wirtschaft bei der
Wochenzeitung Die Zeit herzlich
Willkommen an Julia Löhr
wirtschaftskorrespondentin im
hauptstadtbüro der Frankfurter
Allgemeinen Zeitung in Berlin und
Kristin Schweizer ist von
Mitteldeutschen Rundfunk sie leitet für
den MDR das Studio des Senders in Berlin
fangen wir mal ganz konkret an auch eine
Nachricht aus den letzten Tagen in
Dresden soll der weltweit größte
Chiphersteller TSMC heißt der glaube ich
eine chip-fabrik bauen 10 Milliarden
Euro investieren und 5 Milliarden davon
kommen vom Staat Frau Schwitzer ist das
eine gute Nachricht dass da in einem
moderne Fabrik investiert wird oder ist
es ein Alarmzeichen dass das nur
passiert wenn wir alle so viel
Subvention zahlen ganz ehrlich ich freue
mich darüber ich freue mich dass endlich
Weltkonzerne in Mitteldeutschland
investieren ich glaube dass das eine
ganz ganz große Chance ist das endlich
etwas entsteht unter meine ich nicht TMC
oder Intel oder Infineon sondern das was
darüber hinaus entsteht der Kindergarten
die Bäckerei die Zulieferbetriebe die
Handwerksbetriebe dass eine Struktur
entsteht die darüber hinaus den Menschen
auch mal ein positives Bild vermittelt
das Gefühl ganz vorne dabei sein zu
können teilen Sie das Frau Löhr ist das
vor allem Ausdruck von Fortschritt und
Aufbruch also ich verstehe dass die
Freude vor Ort da groß ist eben weil es
ein positives Signal ist eben nicht nur
Investitionen aus Deutschland abgezogen
sondern es wird auch investiert aber
eben was Frau Schweizer gerade schon
Ansprache auch die Höhe der Subventionen
die gebraucht wird um Unternehmen
hierher zu locken das sehe ich doch
kritisch Subventionen sind gut wenn sie
dazu da sind eine neue Technologie quasi
ihr Starthilfe zu geben als
kundenkopf als er CDU-Ministerpräsident
war in den 90ern die Chip Industrie ja
erstmals quasi in dieser Region nach
Dresden holte da war das der Fall aber
das was neues da war das quasi ein
Startschuss jetzt sind Chips in aller
weltprodukt und ich finde es zu viel
aber jetzt auch wenn man sich das
Beispiel betrachtet das ist eine noch
größere in Magdeburg 30 Milliarden davon
10 Milliarden von uns das sind mehr als
3 Millionen pro Arbeitsplatz also so
viel Ökosystem kann sich darum herum gar
nicht entwickeln dass sich das also noch
zusätzlich entwickeln zu dem was schon
da ist als dass ich das rechnet das Geld
richtig angelegt hat letter ich würde
das sogar noch verstärken die Kritik
daran ich glaube dass Grundproblem ist
nämlich dass wenn einer Situation sind
das eigentlich diese Subventionen
paradigmatisch sind für das Handeln der
Regierung in den letzten Krisen man tut
irgendetwas damit etwas passiert ich
verstehe den Wunsch dass in der Region
was passieren soll und wenn man sich das
anguckt sie sprechen es an 3 Millionen
pro Arbeitsplatz bei Intel ungefähr
zweieinhalb bei TS und sie und das hat
ja folgen aber das hat verschiedene
folgen die relevant sind und die wichtig
sind auch für die Regionen zum einen ist
ja die Annahme es schafft neue
Arbeitsplätze und das andere warum man
das tut und offiziell unterstützt
seitens der Regierung also neben dem
Wohlstand ist die Versorgungssicherheit
und beide Hauptargumente tragen nach
meinem Dafürhalten nicht die
Arbeitsplätze haben zum einen die
Situation dass sie ja nicht nur die
Möglichkeit geben oder in diesem Fall
TSMC Arbeitsplätze zu generieren die
subventioniert werden sondern diese
Unternehmen die momentan anderweitig
erfolgreich sind in einer Zeit in der
wir viel zu wenig Arbeitskräfte haben
ausgebildete Arbeitskräfte suchen werden
diese Unternehmen die mit momentan diese
Arbeitnehmer haben geschädigt durch die
Subventionen weil Intel und die SMC
staatliche Subventionen bekommen um
diese Leute abzuwerben gleichzeitig
subventionieren wir auch noch deren
Aktionäre und das viel größere Problem
finde ich aber die zweite Annahme die
wir treffen die zweite Annahme ist ja
das hilft uns in der
Versorgungssicherheit und was ich gerade
meinte ist ein bisschen Politik im
Effekt wir haben jetzt eine Krise gehabt
wenn wir uns Chips fehlten was tut die
Regierung wir brauchen neue Chips die
Internet Chips die wir bekommen helfen
der Autoindustrie erstmal gar nicht das
sind Chips die sind ausgerichtet auf
ganz andere Technologien die sie in
Handys brauchen und einen anderen
Bereichen das kann später was bringen
und es ist auch möglich dass ein Cluster
entsteht in der Region das mehr
drumherum entsteht das zweite Problem
ist nicht viel problematisch weil die
Autoindustrie die Chips die von TSMC
kommen die man so Schubkarren Ware
relativ einfache Chips die werden
offiziell geholt und der deutschen
Autoindustrie zu helfen es ist aber
nicht die Aufgabe des deutschen
Steuerzahlers die Risiken der deutschen
Autoindustrie zu diversifizieren und zu
bezahlen was ist denn der Effekt davon
wir bezahlen diese Chips oder zumindest
die Ansiedlung dieser
Fabrik während die Manager der deutschen
Automobilkonzerne diese riesigen selbst
gar nicht tragen müssen die könnten doch
genauso sagen mein Gott sie unterstützen
chip-fabriken wir besorgen uns die Chips
aus der halben Welt habt ihr deswegen
halte ich das für eine falsche
Entscheidung und paradigmatisch für die
ampelpolitik danke für die Vertiefung
spannende Aspekte ich gehe noch mal eine
Ebene höher erhäkel meine Frage war ja
ist das ein krisensignal dass wir als
Steuerzahler so viel Geld in die Hand
nehmen müssen damit Firmen bereit sind
bei uns zu investieren oder oder ist es
ein Signal des Aufbruchs dass sie es tun
und das jetzt auch mehr Chips
produzieren also insgesamt ist es glaube
ich kein Signal ist Aufbruchs sondern es
ist ein richtig Signal der tiefen Not in
dieser Entscheidung spiegelt sich zwei
weltweite Veränderung drin die sie
leider bisher nicht berücksichtigt haben
die erste ist dahinter steht natürlich
auch endlich aus der dramatischen
Abhängigkeit rauszukommen von China
indirekt über Teil waren ein ganz
wichtiges Argument die Finanzministerin
USA spricht
heißt also wir müssen neue Standorte
aufbauen die sozusagen nicht neue
politische Abhängigkeit schaffen das ist
eine ganz entscheidende Aspekt zu sein
wir brauchen Chip-Produktion in
Deutschland leider subventioniert ist
der eine Aspekt der zweitaspekt den
haben sie dankswerterweise angesprochen
Frau Löhr ist der das endlich mal eine
Nachricht kommt das nicht irgendwo ist
Ausland investiert wird sondern das
ausländische große Konzern investieren
natürlich dessen ärgerlich wird es teuer
insgesamt bezahlt aber wenn wir wirklich
sozusagen in dieser Welt nicht nur das
seit Corona erfahren haben dass es wenn
es ein kleines lieferkettenproblem gibt
wenn irgendwo ein Shanghai beschäftigt
rauskommt das dann wir im Grunde
genommen die deutsche Wirtschaft dann
wirklich abstürzt dann muss man da
insgesamt Gegenstand des zweite Argument
finde ich auch richtig verschwitze sie
haben das gesagt wichtig ist ich kenne
so ein bisschen die Dresden Seiten Kopf
seit dieser Chip Entscheidung von
Biedenkopf weil ich selber auch mit ihm
darüber gesprochen habe
weiß ich dass hier die Idee nämlich
nicht nur der Chip Produktion jetzt
anzusiedeln in dem Fall von Taiwan
sondern auch dafür zu sorgen dass es
immer Sinn in der Clusterbildung der
forschungsintensive breite Landschaft
gewinnt das des Ziel ist dann ist es
bedauerlich aber dann geht es halt nicht
ohne Subvention ich würde nur bitten
drum oder auffordern dass wenn schon so
viel öfters Geld verbraten werden
Anführungszeichen dass dann auch klare
Auflagen gemacht werden über die Höhe
der Arbeitsplätze über die Höhe der
Wertschöpfung über die Bindung des
Unternehmens nicht ein Standort mal zehn
Jahre aufzumachen da gibt es dann noch
viel zu tun aber am Ende ist es eine
unvermeidbare eine Standort Deutschland
stärken der Entscheidung
sie dürfen wieder sprechen ich tauchen
nur einmal dazwischen einmal weil ich
ihn danke sagen will für die vielen
Kommentare und Fragen bei tagesschau.de
presseclub.de wir verfolgen das hier und
genau das was wir diskutieren ist etwas
was ich in vielen Beiträgen lese warum
müssen wir so viel Geld zahlen damit
Investoren nach Deutschland kommen
ich will ja verspreche Ihnen kein
zahlenkrieg heute aber ich zeige Ihnen
zwei zahlen weil es genau um diese Frage
geht wo investieren deutsche Unternehmen
und diese Grafik zeigt die Investitionen
im Jahr 2022 über 130 Milliarden
investieren deutsche Unternehmen im
Ausland umgekehrt investierten aber nur
10 Milliarden ausländische Unternehmen
bei uns in Deutschland häkel hat das
gerade gesagt Zeichen der Not gute
Nachricht sei dass endlich in
Deutschland investiert würde so und
jetzt ich glaube alle drei wollten er
wieder
einmal kurz ergänzen ich meine ich habe
die Erfahrung gemacht auch in den
letzten 30 Jahren wie oft versucht wurde
etwas anzusehen ja sie haben
Traditionsunternehmen in Sachsen-Anhalt
wie Henkel der Waschmittelhersteller der
irgendwann gesagt hat das ist hier
entstandort da kann ich nicht bleiben
das rentiert sich nicht sie haben große
Unternehmen wie Haribo die in Dresden in
Sachsen die Fabrik zu gemacht haben und
wir haben halt einfach viel zu oft
erlebt
große Firmen kommen aber nicht bleiben
deswegen finde ich diesen Gedanken den
sie haben genau diesen Gedanken den sie
haben sehr wichtig klar kommt es jetzt
darauf an welche Verträge gemacht werden
und das nicht das Geld einfach nur mit
der Gießkanne ausgegossen wird sondern
das tatsächlich auch Strukturen
passieren die Landesregierung in
Sachsen-Anhalt muss da jetzt ein
Industriepark aus dem Boden stampfen um
auch einfach die anderen
Standortfaktoren und die weichen
Standortfaktoren gewährleistet
infrastrukturiert ja also wir haben die
A2 wir haben die A14 das viel passiert
vielleicht ist auch mal gute Nachricht
zu sagen da ist viel passiert nach der
Wende was jetzt auch Früchte tragen kann
also wir haben eine sehr sehr gute
Forschungslandschaft in jeder größeren
Stadt in Leipzig in Magdeburg
frauenhofer-institut Max planck-institut
leibnitz-institut und deswegen ist jetzt
vielleicht der richtige Moment und das
aus meiner Sicht lohnt eben diese
subventionelle
bei dieser ganzen Debatte ist die Frage
so setzen wir unser Geld also das ist ja
letztlich das Geld von uns allen von uns
Steuern Zahlern effizient ein und ich
finde man müsste schon klarer auch
darüber reden was wären denn die
alternativen also mit diesen zehn
Milliarden für Intel könnte man den Etat
des Forschungsministeriums um die Hälfte
um 50 Prozent aufstocken man könnte 300
ICE kaufen man könnte jeden der 50.000
Jugendlichen die jedes Jahr die Schule
ohne Abschluss verlassen mit 200.000
Euro helfen in den Arbeitsmarkt
reinzukommen also ich glaube wir sind in
einer Zeit in der wir begrenzte Mittel
haben also wir müssen einfach Haushalten
mit unserem Geld und wir müssen mehr
darüber reden ist das jetzt tatsächlich
die Investitionen die Deutschland
weiterbringt und ich sehe mit Sorge dass
zum Beispiel ein Unternehmen wie Marvel
Fusion das ist ein Startup was sich um
das Thema Kernfusionen also wo es um
energievermehrung geht und neue
Kraftwerke ein deutsches Unternehmen
aus München jetzt seinen nächsten
Schritt in Amerika machen wird weil es
halt einfach sagt da sind für uns die
Übungen besser an der Chef von man
energy dass die beschäftigen sich somit
Energietechnik der hat neulich gesagt
Sie haben Anlagen in Deutschland
entwickelt zum quasi Abscheiden von CO2
also zum Verpressen von CO2 um es aus
der Atmosphäre zu holen oder bei
Produktionsprozessen zu speichern auch
das verkaufen sie nach Amerika weil es
hier verboten ist also wir sind glaube
ich also wir rennen da gerade bei dieser
Chip-Produktion ja in der corona-krise
gab es einen Engpass alle Welt hat aber
jetzt in chip-fabriken investiert
experten sagen wir laufen da tatsächlich
schon in Überkapazitäten rein und da
geben wir jetzt viele viele Milliarden
rein die man aus meiner Sicht sinnvoller
an andere
Information sie sind dann dran und dann
verheckel es auch schon wieder
gedanklich aktiv ich will eine
Information bei verlöer ist angesprochen
hat anschließend wir haben ja einen
Wettbewerb in dem die USA mit über 300
Milliarden Dollar genau das tun was bei
uns im Einzelfall passiert nämlich
Industrieunternehmen nach Amerika locken
er beiden kann jede Woche irgendwo eine
tolle neue Fabrik Einbein VW geht mit
einer großen Batterieproduktion nach
South Carolina es gibt Unternehmen eins
aus der Schweiz das im Solarbereich in
Bitterfeld investieren wollte jetzt nach
Colorado geht also dahinter steckt ein
großes Muster und wenn die USA mit
Wachstum in diesem Jahr rechnen können
und wir mit Schrumpfung spiegelt das ein
bisschen so wer wie erfolgreich
Unternehmen ansiedelt das als Einschub
und jetzt können Sie gerne auch völlig
richtig nein ich würde dazu gern was
sagen ganz kurz nur noch zu der Frage
Versorgungssicherheit wir sind nämlich
trotz der schöpferfabriken weiterhin
abhängig von Seltenen Erden aus China
und so weiter deswegen ist natürlich
überhaupt nichts gewonnen wie sie gerade
meinen aber zu der Frage mit Amerika das
ist tatsächlich interessant auch die
Zahl die Sie gerade eingeblendet haben
also das ist mehr direkt Investitionen
im Ausland aus Deutschland gibt als
Investitionen bei uns das ist auch
erstmal eine ökonomische Folge eines
Exportüberschusses also Geld jetzt hier
rein fließt muss auch wieder irgendwo
anders investiert werden
nichtsdestotrotz gibt es dieses Problem
dass der Standort für viele Unternehmen
nicht mehr attraktiv ist und ich glaube
wir erzählen uns mit diesem
amerikanischen unterstützungspaketen
auch ein bisschen eine Selbstlüge es ist
richtig dass das sehr sehr viel gemacht
wird und tatsächlich auch noch deutlich
mehr als sie gesagt haben weil
erhebliche Teile dieser Programme nach
hinten offen sind weil sie als Steuer
Gutschriften im Nachhinein geltend
gemacht werden können die eigentliche
Frage ist aber eine andere die Frage ist
kommen diese Unternehmen die dahin gehen
wirklich ausschließlich wegen dieser
Subventionen wir haben ja in Europa in
diesen Feldern erneuerbare Energien und
viele andere Sachen ähnlich hohe Summen
auch wenn sie nicht ganz so hoch sind in
den letzten Jahren und Jahrzehnten
ausgegeben zumal die Summen in Amerika
aber viele Jahre gestreckt sind das
eigentliche Problem in Amerika sind ganz
anderes der Wirtschaftsminister von
Georgia Weinen bis zum letzten Jahr fünf
Mal in Deutschland bei deutschen
Unternehmen um die abzuwerden und was
war das ein Argument der sagte wir
bringen jetzt zwei Atomkraftwerke an den
Staat
der Strom ist bei uns echt billig und
der CO2 neutral und wir gehen aus der
Kohle raus und sie haben in Amerika eben
neben diesen Förderungen und diese
zweifelsohne gibt das sind große tickets
eine viel bessere verwaltungslage viel
weniger Bürokratie man rollt in den
roten Teppich aus und sie haben was man
nicht vergessen darf in Amerika eine
Situation die sind in den letzten Jahren
Energie netto Exporteur geworden weil
sie Franken weil sie eben diese Abwägung
die wir hier treffen wir wollen also
alles ganz perfekt machen und das wird
nicht gehen wir werden entweder
Kompromisse machen müssen beim Standort
dahingehend dass wir sagen wir werden
alle normativen Wünsche die wir haben
nicht umsetzen können dass wir jedes
Windrad vor Vögeln schützen oder
andersrum und wir werden aber
gleichzeitig auch den Kompromiss machen
müssen dass wir nicht jeder
Bürgerinitiative nachgeben und dass wir
vielleicht auch Freihandelsabkommen mit
Ländern machen von denen wir Wasserstoff
bekommen wo es uns überhaupt nicht
gefällt
und wenn ich noch hinzufügen darf die
niedrigeren Steuern kommen auch noch
dazu ist eines der hoch steuerländer ja
ich versuche ganz wichtig wir kommen im
Grunde bis Deutschland zur Zeit die
Industrie ihr rede nur über die
Industrie er doppelten Druck einerseits
aus der Abhängigkeit von China indirekt
Taiwan rauskommt könnt ihr auch sein
eine kluge Politik in anführungsschein
möglicherweise dass ein Taiwan was
passiert mit China dass das eine wir
machen es relativ unabhängig friend re
shoring wir gehen in die demokratisch
nahen Freund beschreibt Freundschaft und
Ländern und das zweite haben wir jetzt
ausführlich diskutiert nämlich die
Abwanderung nach USA immer ist doch ganz
ganz wichtig mal die Frage zu stellen
warum wandern so viel ich habe das so
vorbereitet Setzung unseres Gespräch das
alles nochmal sehr genau angeschaut das
Haupt es gibt zwei Hauptmotive das eine
Hauptmotiv ist in der Tat wir haben
unser krisenproblem nicht bewältigt
darum das müssen wir lösen sind die
hohen Industrie sind die hohen Energie
bzw Strompreise Frage Klammer auf was
kann man da machen
überbrückungsstrategien will ich jetzt
die diskutieren das zweite ist das ähm
wir sind in einer neuen und die womit
überrascht dass sie das nicht
thematisieren wir sind einer sehr
aggressiven der Phase des
Protektionismus bei America bzw Amerika
first erscheint jetzt in einer
demokratisch sympathischen Variante
gegenüber Trump aber es ist jetzt dieser
Redaktion Act mit 330 Milliarden Dollar
das ist nicht alles wie sie sagen ist
eine unglaubliche Abwerbung jetzt ist
die Frage wie gehen wir damit um und da
ist eine Antwort wir müssen unser
Energieproblem lösen wir müssen
runterkommen von den hohen Energiepreis
in den entscheidende Rolle spielen bei
der Steuer bin ich unsicher also meine
Untersuchung oder unsere Untersuchung
zeigen dass die steuergefälle zu USA
nicht entscheiden wenn Sie heute in
Unternehmen gehen bei BASF bei VW etwa
mit der von Ihnen abgesprochen
angesprochenen Batterie verbringt raus
Carolina dann gibt es eigentlich ein
Hauptargument erstens es sind die viel
zu hohen Energiepreise da haben sie viel
dazu gesagt frage wie lösen und das
zweite ist übrigens kriegen wir noch ein
Geschenk dazu während dem wir uns
aufregen darüber auch zu Recht finde ich
weil wir da gut beraten sind warum wir
für Intel warum wir jetzt für Tai waren
warum er im Saarland subventionieren
Chip-Produktion ist in den USA ganz
andere Prozess der wird deutsche indust
wie hochwertige wertvolle Industrie wird
abgeworben mit mit dem was man
eigentlich gedacht hatte was im
Welthandel abgeschafft ist nämlich im
brutalen Protektionismus auf dem müssen
wir antworten und dann versteht man
vielleicht auch die Entscheidung Dresden
und anderen schauen bisschen besser das
ist aber ich würde gerne einmal sind
auch andere Bedingungen einmal sie haben
in sehr dankbar ich glaube wir haben die
Lage was die Investitionen angeht
wirklich von vielen Seiten beleuchtet
ganz besonderer Aspekt ist mehrfach
genannt worden dass in Ostdeutschland
Strukturen aufgebaut wurden die jetzt
verstärkt werden dass es dort regionale
Gründe für diese Investitionen gibt die
nicht zu unterschätzen sind ist die
Frage gestellt worden insgesamt das Geld
vernünftig ausgegeben wird ob man mit
dem Geld auf anderen Wegen mehr hätte
tun können und wir haben dargestellt
welches Gefälle gerade im run um
Investitionen entsteht aus Deutschland
raus in die USA und in andere Länder sie
haben begonnen Ursachen zu benennen das
würde ich weiteren Teil der Debatte
jetzt gerne Punkt für Punkt auch tun ich
will nur eine Frage einschieben und
bitte sie da alle um eine kurze
Antworten nämlich wie dramatisch ist die
Lage ich frage das deshalb weil wir mit
sehr unterschiedlichen Begriffen im
Moment operieren von einer Delle ist die
Rede von einer Flaute der
Konjunkturmotor stottert das klingt so
man muss nun mal wieder Gas geben andere
sprechen von einer Strukturkrise das
Wort das die Kritiker am stärksten
verwenden heißt die Industrialisierung
also ich sag mal von Flaute Flaute ist
wenn der nächste Wind schon in der
Vorhersage angesagt ist bis zu die
Industrialisierung das ist kaltschlag
das ist so die Skala der Bewertung
deshalb vielleicht jeweils bitte nur
eine kurze persönliche Bewertung wo sind
wir auf dieser Skala
im Titel der Sendung gefragt ob wir
abgehängt sind und ich würde sagen noch
sind wir nicht abgehängt aber wir laufen
Gefahr abgehängt zu werden eben durch
diese Situation und stagniert die
Wirtschaft in anderen Ländern wächst sie
wieder und es gab gerade eine versuchen
von der Brüsseler Denkfabrik die gesagt
hat wenn das so weitergeht dann wird in
zehn Jahren das Wohlstandsgefälle
zwischen den Amerikanern und uns so groß
sein wie heute das zwischen den
Europäern und den inderen also das damit
kann man sich mal so vor Augen führen
was das heißt wenn halt die anderen uns
immer weiter dann jetzt enteilen und von
daher würde ich sagen ja wir müssen auf
jeden Fall was machen auf den Punkt der
Hecke wie es ihre einschätze also den
Industrialisierung halte ich für extrem
unverantwortlich während dem die
deutsche Industrie dabei ist sich im
ökologischen Transformationsprozess
Industrie schluckteil neu aufzustellen
halt für unmöglich zweitens wir sind
interessant wie die Ziffern 0,3 % minus
des international Währungsfonds
vorletzter Woche wie die plötzlich jetzt
apokalyptisch in interpretiert wird ich
sage einfach die Deutsche Bundesbank in
dem Fall seriöse Prognose andere
Institut sagen uns im nächsten Jahr
haben wir wieder 1,2%. das heißt wir
sind in einer Phase da Wachstumsschwäche
aber das größte Problem ist dass vieles
bewältigt werden muss beispielsweise
energiepreisindustriepreis
die Regierung sozusagen
wahrgenommeneur habe ich verstanden ihre
Bewertung es wird ja auch viel vom
kranken Mann Europas wieder gesprochen
ich finde es schwierig man sollte jetzt
nicht es schlimmer herbei reden als
tatsächlich ist aber eine Flaute wäre
wahrscheinlich auch zu wenig ich glaube
dass wir strukturelle Probleme haben die
über viele viele Jahre liegen geblieben
sind und dass wir endlich mal Mut haben
sollten vielleicht in dieser Krise auch
ernsthaftere Formen anzugehen
ich glaube das apokalyptisch muss man
noch nicht sein ich glaube was wir
gerade sehen ist dass die
großen Krisen Corona und Ukraine Krieg
strukturelle Themen die wir ohnehin
hatten vertiefen und beschleunigen das
sind drei Hauptthemen dass die
Energieversorgung durch die
dekaronisierung was Kurzform gegen die
Wand fahren ist das ist die Frage wie
wir die demografische Frage hinkriegen
dass immer weniger junge mehr alte und
Sozialkassen finanzieren müssen was wir
gesehen haben in der letzten Krise die
Verteilungskonflikte die aufbrechen als
dritte große Thema was Erik als
Protektionismus Ansprache würde ich
sagen eher das Zurückfahren der
Globalisierung von der wir profitiert
haben und uns zu beantworten in den
einzelnen Themen aber ist okay ich habe
verstanden jedenfalls sag mal dass
niemand die Situation als harmlos
bewertet sondern alle als ernsthaft nur
das Ausmaß sozusagen unterschiedlich
bewertet wird ein User bei Twitter fragt
auf unserem Kanal ist die gescheiterte
Energiewende die Mutter der die
Industrialisierung das ist dieses Thema
Energiepreise das jetzt verschiedene von
ihnen angesprochen haben also fangen wir
bei der Ursachen Analyse damit an Sie
haben es zuerst erwähnt also wie
verantwortlich sind die hohen
Energiepreise in Deutschland für die
wirtschaftliche Situation die wir
beschrieben haben im Gesamtbild sehr
schlimm je nach Branche unterschiedlich
es gibt Branchen die trifft das Meer und
es gibt Branchen die trifft das weniger
werden sicher vielleicht auch noch über
den industriestrompreis sprechen die
Frage ist sagen Sie gleich das ist ja
sozusagen die politische Antwort die
politische Antwort ist tatsächlich wir
unterstützen jetzt einzelne Branchen
einzelne Industrien das ist zumindest
die Idee wird das Minister Weg verfolgt
ich persönlich bin da sehr ambivalent
weil einerseits ist es so dass wir
natürlich ein Land sind das einen
wo die Industrie eine große Rolle spielt
gleichzeitig ist Industrie nicht
zwingend nötig für Wohlstand sie haben
in Amerika halb so viele Industrie wie
hier und ein deutlich höheres pro Kopf
Einkommen und mehr Wachstum aber unsere
Struktur ist so und Wirtschaft geht
immer dahin wo die Energie ist als
Industrie deswegen haben wir auch im
Ruhrpott eben viel unternehmen die Kohle
brauchen und das hat sich eben massiv
geändert dass der industrielle Kern
nicht mehr versorgt wird und deswegen
ist diese Energiefrage für die
Planungssicherheit von Unternehmen eine
ganz zentrale und wenn die nicht glauben
und deswegen ist dieser
brückenstrompreis von dem habe ich
spricht der industriestrompreis als
Subventionierung das ist eine Wette die
steht und fällt mit der Frage ob es uns
gelingt wirklich in einigen Jahren zu
wettbewerbsfähigen Zeitpunkt helfen euch
ein paar Jahre bis dann durch modernere
Energieversorgung der
Stromanlagen und viele Windräder und
alles wird großartig und das ist sehr
unwahrscheinlich weil wir die
Speichertechnologien in dieser Form
wahrscheinlich nicht hinkriegen und weil
wir keinen natürlicher Standort sind für
erneuerbare Energien das ist anderswo
einfach besser stimmig Herrn kletter
voll zu ich finde den Begriff
brückenstrompreis der ist irreführend
bzw wir sind letztlich auf einer Brücke
wo wir überhaupt nicht wissen ob wir das
Ufer erreichen was ich dahinter oder was
damit versprochen wird das Ufer ist ja
im Sinne von Robert Habeck wenn wir
erstmal genug erneuerbare haben dann
wird Strom ganz günstig werden Wind und
Sonne schicken keine Rechnung das ist ja
immer dieses Jahr diese viel zitierte
hoffnungsfaktor nur eben wie sie ja
richtig sagen Deutschland ist nicht das
Land was der ideale Standorte für
erneuerbare Energien ist gerade im
Winter wenn wir eine hohe Energiebedarf
haben erst recht mit den ganzen
Elektroautos Wärmepumpen die Industrie
brauchen mehr Strom werden wir also
brauchen wir entweder gigantische
Speicher die ist bislang noch nicht gibt
oder wir haben ein Problem und das
Problem mit gelöst durch Gaskraftwerke
durch wasserstoffkraftwerke die eben
dann einspringen wenn wir nicht genug
erneuerbare Energien haben die wiederum
sind aber teuer also diese Brücke hin zu
einem was sollten wir stattdessen tun
das Energieangebot erhöhen also das ist
ja letztlich das wenn der Preis zu hoch
ist dann versucht man das Angebot zu
vergrößern leider hat die Regierung
gerade das Gegenteil gemacht indem sie
die Atomkraftwerke abgestellt
naja wir sind ich glaube wir sind
doppelter Schwierigkeit indem wir jetzt
mal Politik uns alle sozusagen die
Pflicht wir sind auf Schwierigkeit die
kein Lehrbuch vorkommt wir haben auf der
einen Seite durch die ukraine-krise
durch den Krieg Russlands haben wir auf
der einen Seite den Explosion explosiven
preisanstiegenden Energiewirtschaft
übrigens politisch gewollt durch das
Verzicht durch das Verbot zu schaffen
Gas geben wollten wir politisch es hat
einen hohen Preis die Preise nach oben
gegangen das zweite ist wir waren
eigentlich in einem relativ als bevor
das kam drei vier Monate waren wir im
relativ gemütlichen Prozess der
ökologischen Umbaus und da hat die
energiepreiserhöhung reingehauen wie
eine Bombe und jetzt müssen wir uns
neues sortieren und wir sind das
Situation wo die Bundesregierung im
Grunde genommen mit zwei Maßnahmen
gezeigt hat das ist Problem nicht
richtig begriffen hat habe kein zwei
schwere Fehler gemacht die uns jetzt
Akzeptanz kostet in der Industrie in der
Gesellschaft der erste war die Gast bei
ist Umlage das wird der zweite warte
heizungsaustausch so eine Aktion
anzukündigen dass ich zu Hause von
Heizkörper stehe und frage was ich
machen muss das war ein schwerer Fehler
was wir jetzt brauchen ist da haben sich
Demmin recht es gibt das Bild von
Schumpeter von der schöpferischen
Zerstörung wir sind gerade dabei zur
zerstören die bisherige fossile
Industriestruktur und sind dabei in
einem da bin übrigens sehr viel
optimistisch einem schöpferischen
Prozess sozusagen neuer
Industriestrukturen ohne Fossil da steht
für mich Queen Stil wo die ganzen
Stahlwerke in Deutschland vorbildliche
Arbeit leisten aber die Frage ist und
die kann ich auch nicht ganz genau
beantworten schaffen wir es diese
Überbrückung hinzubekommen schaffen wir
es sozusagen das gemessen an dem was
jetzt an fossiler Energie zurückgeht
erneuert Industriestruktur aufzubauen
das dauert Zeit und deshalb finde ich
den Begriff der Überbrückung im
Gegensatz zu ihnen leider völlig
tauglich das sind taugt ja Begriff wir
müssen genau an das Ufer kommen an dem
wieder es ist wichtig Energie billiger
wird aber auch Energie
verantwortungsaffen
aber sie wird nie so günstig sein wie in
Amerika die in ihrer Energie
solange wir importieren müssen sind wir
a von anderen abhängig was wir ja
eigentlich auch nicht sein wollen und B
müssen wir dafür bezahlen zeigen uns wir
können das schaffen wir können auch mit
Solarenergie mit Windenergie weil da
kenne mich ein bisschen aus über die
Windanlagen die da gebaut werden und von
den Kollegen die Wissenschaft befördern
der das können wir schaffen ist ungemein
schwierig aber eins ist da da stehen wir
Ihnen zu Deutschland wir müssen die den
Mut haben des Energieproblem nicht zu
lösen wie die USA auf der Basis von
Fracking mir wird schlecht wenn der LG
angeliefert wird in Wilhelms haben
zurzeit und ich weiß genau wie das
entstanden durch Fracking also danke
danke
Pfad sozusagen einer ökologischen
zukünftige Energie und das ist aber
schwierig danke für Ihren direkten
Austausch auch weil klar wird welche
Dimension das Problem hat und sie haben
das Wort Wette genannt und in der Tat
gibt es unterschiedliche Annahmen ob das
eine Brücke ans andere Ufer oder eine
Brücke ins Nichts wird die Meinungen
dazu sind unterschiedlich ja ich habe so
ein paar Stichworte im Hinterkopf
notiert Bürokratie
[Gelächter]
seit vielen Bundesregierungen könnte man
schon sagen reden
und die berühmten
Planfeststellungsverfahren die nicht
schnell genug laufen und die digitale
Verwaltung die auch nicht schnell genug
läuft wir wissen das das Problem ist wir
reden halt einfach sehr sehr lange schon
darüber aber es passiert nicht und
irgendwann versteht der Bürger glaube
ich nicht mehr sagt dass zum Beispiel
das lieferkettengesetz enorm viel mehr
Bürokratie schaffe nicht nur das und
dahinter stehen ja auch politische Ziele
Menschenrechte einhalten ökologische
Dinge also geht Bürokratieabbau ohne
das ist auch wichtig ohne
gesellschaftliche Ziele aufgeben aber
man kann schon an der ein oder anderen
Stelle Bürokratie abbauen es gibt ja
eine Initiative aus dem
Bundesjustizministerium eine Abfrage bei
den Handwerkskammern etc die sagen es
gibt kleine Stellschrauben an denen man
drehen kann und da ist eben die
Beantragung von Verfahren von
genehmigungsver anderen
Planfeststellungsverfahren Rückmeldungen
von Behörden das könnte man einfordern
einen Vorschlag vom DIHK dass man da
einige Verfahren beschleunigt bei den
Ausbildungshilfen oder bei der
Ausbildung
Bürokratie abzubauen manche Sachen
dürfen einfach nicht digital passieren
da muss man gesetzliche Regelungen
ändern es gibt die Überlegung auch
im Bundesfinanzministerium
Steuererleichterungen zu machen manchmal
sind auch die kleinen Stellschrauben die
helfen könnten
nicht einfach steuern für Unternehmen
und für Fachkräfte senken statt
Subventionen zu zahlen auch eine
Möglichkeit ja also auch eine
Möglichkeit um mal ein Signal zu senden
und zu sagen wir tun etwas und wir
fragen uns nicht im kleinen und streiten
über heizungsgesetze sondern wir machen
an diesen kleinen steinschrauben etwas
und wenn es viele kleine Stellschrauben
sind hauptsache es passiert was ich
glaube das ist ein bisschen die
Wahrnehmung der Menschen ja kommt man
beim Bürokratie und Steuern über den
guten Vorsatz hinaus ich würde da gerne
was unpopuläres sagen ich glaube wir
müssen uns entscheiden ob wir
moralisch reich und ökonomisch ärmer
sein wollen oder andersrum also es ist
so weil
Bürokratie hat ja auch eine Funktion sie
schützt den Bürger vor dem Staat und vor
Willkür und der Verwaltungsgerichte
sorgen dafür dass der Bürger geschützt
wird ganz erhebliche
bürokratie-hemmnisse die wir bei der
Energiewende haben haben mit Bürgerrecht
und Bürger Einsprüchen und so weiter zu
tun und wir müssen uns schon entscheiden
wollen wir dass die Bürger weiter auf
dieser Ebene mitreden oder sonst die
gesamte Energieversorgung wichtiger die
gleiche Frage werden bei vielen anderen
Fragen stellen müssen auch bei den
Widerstand gegen Atomkraft und andere
Fragen und wenn man gerade
entschuldigung
das ist ja dann individuelles Recht
gegen gesellschaftlich und diese
Abwägungen treffen wir natürlich immer
die Frage ist ob sie anders treffen
müssen das passiert zum Teil es gab zum
Beispiel jetzt diese Gesetze im letzten
Jahr das sogenannte osterpaket war sehr
nett verpackt indem man
Wirtschaftsministerium versucht hat
bestimmte Verfahren bei erneuerbaren
Energien beim Ausbau der erneuerbaren
Energien zu beschleunigen das kommt zu
bedingt an es geht ein ein bisschen aber
reicht bei weitem nicht also wir hatten
neulich Herrn Birnbaum den CEO von Eon
bei uns im Interview und der beschrieb
dass sie seit 2017
Planfeststellungsverfahren für
Infrastruktur offen haben von denen seit
2017 0 Verfahren genehmigt wurden und
jetzt ist die Frage wie zum Teufel
wollen wir es schaffen wenn wir zehn
Jahre lang brauchen für eine große
Trasse von Norden nach Süden wenn wir
sieben oder sechs oder fünf Jahre
brauchen für sein blödes Windrad wenn
wir schon stolz sind auf LG Terminals
das sind schwimmende kleine Schiffe mit
irgendwelchen 30 Kilometern Pipeline und
aber wenn wir darauf stolz sind dass wir
unsere eigene Bürokratie in einer
Notsituation besiegt haben und sowas
hingekriegt haben damit die Leute nicht
frieren und die Fabriken laufen dann
frage ich mich schon wie sollen wir
203035 schaffen alles umzubauen und
deswegen würde ich sagen die Debatte die
wir führen über Bürokratie ist
eigentlich eine große gesellschaftliche
verhandlungsdebatte in die dann auch
eine sozialpolitische
verteilungsparteien gehört wir müssen
nämlich auch und das ist was das Scholz
in seinen Aussagen unterschlägt er
spricht da vom neuen Wirtschaftswunder
das ist natürlich völliger Unsinn es
wird ja nicht wie nach dem
wirtschaftswundern neue Fabrik gebaut es
wird ein altes durch ein neues Kraftwerk
ersetzt das heißt wir haben nicht die
Wachstumsraten wie damals was zur Folge
hat dass wir ärmer werden und die Frage
ist wie verteilen wir die Lasten und das
wird auch zur Folge haben dass wir uns
fragen müssen ob wir bestimmte
Industrien hier noch halten können und
ob wir vielleicht für den Stahl oder für
andere Branchen vielleicht keine Heimat
mehr sind und uns überlegen müssen wie
können wir wie können wir das Geld dass
wir jetzt für Subventionen bezahlen so
einsetzen dass der zukunftsträchtige
Branchen entstehen und wir die Sachen
aus Ländern Einkaufen die sie
subventionieren ist doch ein guter Deal
für uns also wir haben das Thema
Bürokratie Steuern kurz angesprochen
wir haben über die Energie gesprochen
das Stichwort dass ich ja auch bei den
Userinnen und Usern immer lese sie auch
schon genannt haben ist der Arbeits- und
Fachkräftemangel
welchen Einfluss welches Gewicht hat das
für unsere Krisensituation erlauben wir
den Einsatz doch zu steuern sagen so
läuft flott hier zu sagen wir senken die
Steuern ist natürlich schon
problematisch wir haben ein Problem wir
haben ja in der schien seine völlig neue
Haushaltspolitik wir haben den
Bundeshaushalt der wird gekürzt der wird
Steuersenkungen dazu führen ganz in dem
Sinne was sie vorangeführt das wichtige
sozialpolitische Aufgaben ökologisch
auch wenn nicht mehr funktionieren ne
starte kein Geld und wir haben jetzt den
ganzen Umbau haben wir sozusagen in den
klimaforge sind wirklich Haushalt lassen
Sie uns mit Blick auf die USA einfach
die Feststellung dass Unternehmen
Steuern bei uns deutlich höher sind als
andersherum ja ich würde nur gerne
dieses Thema glaube ich und dann noch
mal
Bürokratie wenn Sie jetzt hier eine
Abstimmung machen würden würden wir alle
sagen ja wir haben eine riesengroßes
Fachkräfte Problem man kann
facharbeitskräfte Problem wer kann
darüber nachdenken woher es gekommen ist
führt uns jetzt aber auch nicht
unbedingt weiter wir tun uns wir tun wir
sind sehr aktiv in im Bereich der
Ausbildung Ausbildungsbereich desto
lösen auf der anderen Seite werden wir
und das ist dir keine neue these aber
durch Migration durch kluge
Migrationspolitik werden wir die Lücke
einigermaß für in Deutschland kann aus
eigener Kraft die
facharbeiterkraft-lücke Facharbeiterin
Kraft Lücke nicht schließen das sind wir
auch da ähnlich wie bei der Energie in
seiner brückensituation wir wissen was
wir brauchen würden
aber noch ist nicht sichtbar wo das Ufer
ist im Gegenteil wir reden alle drüber
wir reden alle drüber es gibt auch tolle
Statistik es gibt tolle Analysen aber
den Weg was muss passieren welche Rolle
hat zum Beispiel das
Forschungsministerium
Bildungsministerium auf Bundesebene in
diesem Transformationsprozess dass er ja
eigentlich gar keine Aktivität also da
gibt es sozusagen wirkt den Satz der
Erkenntnisstand ist hoch der
handlungsstand die handlungsreaktion
sind relativ schwer die Frage ist ja
nicht nur was wir wollen sondern auch
was die Fachkräfte wollen die zu uns
kommen könnten und nicht umsonst sind
Länder wie Kanada und Amerika eben bei
den Fachkräften diesem Moment weitaus
attraktiver als wir das sind womit wir
wieder bei den hohen Steuern sind bei
den hohen Energiepreisen wir haben keine
Wohnungen für die Fachkräfte wir haben
keine Kitaplätze wir haben keine
Facharzttermine also Deutschland ist
gerade
das ist natürlich könnte man sich mit
Englisch kommt man ja auch durchaus
jetzt in Deutschland schon weiter aber
wir müssen da bin ich wieder bei diesem
Thema Strukturreform wir müssten
tatsächlich auch mehr tun um attraktiver
zu werden und ein zweiter großer Punkt
ist eben auch das Thema an dass ich kein
Politiker ran traut das heimische
Fachkräftepotenzial die Rente mit 63 ob
wir nicht doch mal das
Renteneintrittsalter an die gestiegene
Lebenserwartung anfangen
aber ich frag sie trotzdem kurz weil es
nicht so umgetrieben hat Herr März hat
vorgeschlagen Überstunden steuerfrei zu
machen das fand ich ein entspannenden
Anreiz um mehr Arbeit attraktiv zu
machen
Mosaikstein irgendwie reingeworfen der
löst aber nicht unser Problem bei
Großunternehmen gehen die Überstunden
auf Freizeit konnten werden Freizeit
ausgeglichen Millionen Überstunden im
Jahr werden überhaupt nicht ausgeglichen
also ja das mag für manchen kleinen
Handwerksbetrieb attraktiv sein aber das
löst nicht unser Problem lauter Themen
von denen wir wissen wenn wir sehr gut
sind können wir die in paar Jahren
gelöst haben und ganz aktuell
gehen wir aber in die Delle und fallen
zurück gegenüber anderen
Volkswirtschaften die Frage hier wird
sie so formuliert im Netz warum wird
nicht die Schuldenbremse gelockert und
ein Konjunkturpaket geschnürt um die
Wirtschaft in Fahrt zu bringen wir
wissen nach der Debatte das ist nicht
die Lösung aber könnte von mir kommen
die Lösung noch eine Weile Dauer und das
ist doch genau die Diskussion die sie
jetzt in Berlin beobachten ja aber wir
verschieben damit die strukturellen
Notwendigkeiten oder die Reform der
strukturellen Notwendigkeiten wir können
die Schuldenbremse aussetzen das müssen
sie dann aber die nächsten Generation
erklären warum wir das tun also ja ja
also wir können sie nicht dauerhaft
aussetzen und ich glaube das Signal wäre
einfach fatal an künftige Generationen
wir waren auf einem sehr guten Weg
niemand kann was für den Krieg niemand
kann was für die Pandemie das ist völlig
klar ich glaube eher dass man den Mut
haben sollte deswegen habe ich das
vorhin auch gesagt was haben wir gemacht
vor 20 Jahren eine Arbeitsmarktreform
die hat viel Kraft gekostet sie haben es
vorhin gesagt wir müssen dann eben auch
mal Einschnitte woanders hinnehmen wenn
man wenn man etwas erreichen will es
wäre Zeit für eine strukturelle Reform
in Deutschland von der Verwaltung über
wirtschaftliche Konjunktur etc also mal
wirklich etwas mit Mut anzufassen und zu
sagen wir gehen diese strukturellen
Probleme an dann wird es jetzt
vielleicht noch ein bisschen Brücken
Arbeit geben müssen aber ich glaube dass
dieser Mut fehlt mir ein bisschen und
man könnte diese Krise nutzen um genau
die ganz grundlegenden Dinge anzuschoßen
haben ein großes Konjunkturpaket also
mit Bezug auf die Schuldenbremse finde
ich eine skurrile Idee sicher anders als
er häkeln wenn sie gerade über den Tisch
schon richtig verstanden habe
also die ganze Schuldenbremse Debatte
findet da seit Jahren in
unterschiedlichen Kulissen immer wieder
statt die hat auch in der Makroökonomie
sicher so ein Gewissen theologischen
Wert ja also man Realwert und ja so dass
das ist auf jeden Fall das aber auch und
für die Koalition vielleicht auch ein
metaphysischen so eine
entlastungsfantasie aber ich glaube im
Kern ist die Schulden Debatte und die
Schuldenbremse Debatte und die
Konjunkturprogramm Debatte die kann man
ja grundsätzlich führen aber ich frage
mich warum jetzt wir haben Haushalte in
denen zig Milliarden ungenutzt herum
liegen selbst wenn man das professionell
begleitet und verliert den Überblick es
gibt
zig Milliarden an kreditanächtigungen
die von einem Topf in den nächsten
gestopft werden und dann haben wir eine
Regierung mit einer Familienministerin
die tritt also an und sagt 12 Milliarden
Kindergrundsicherung unbedingt die
Koalition ganz wichtig ganz ganz
wichtig
passt die dritte also 12 Millionen
Kindergrundsicherung ich weiß aber nicht
wofür obwohl das ja ein wichtiges Thema
ist dass wir die Chancen von Kindern von
den Eltern Herkunft entkoppeln aber sie
hat also keine Idee was sie mit dem Geld
anfangen will und auf dem Niveau
diskutieren wir
ein bisschen Geld und überlegen was man
will dringend sagen Distanz überraschen
sowohl an die Gewerkschaften als auch
ein Herr März streichen Sie sofort den
Begriff Konjunkturprogramm der Begriff
Konjunkturprogramm führt in die Irre was
wir brauchen ist ein infrastrukturelles
Programm das haben wir jetzt im Klima
und transformationstag der Klima
Transformation ist ja im Grunde genommen
anders finanziert nicht über Schulden
sondern über CO2 also reden sie nicht
von Konjunkturprogramm sondern wir
brauchen wenn man es gab mal 1982 die
berühmte alte arbeitsmäßig Ehrenberg der
dem schmittenprogramm abgeschlossen
Punkt
200 Milliarden innerhalb von vier Jahren
aus dem Kino
mehr wenn man das Vergleich mit Amerika
der Bevölkerung dort
in dem Zeitraum dort das ist mehr als
die Amerikaner ins Schaufenster gestellt
haben es fehlt uns nicht am Geld es
fehlt genau
ich habe Ihnen aufmerksam zugehört und
eine Menge gelernt nicht nur über
Sichtweisen sondern auch über Fakten
danke für die Analyse
bedanke mich bei Ihnen bedanke mich im
Netz jetzt hier bei Phoenix im Netz und
bei WDR 5 Presseclub nachgefragt wenn
sie in der ARD dabei bleiben folgt
lieber Herr Ekel liebe Frau Löhr das
Europa Magazin unter anderem mit einem
Blick auf die Situation in Slowenien
nach der Flut bis hierhin danke tschüss
und lassen Sie es gut gehen
und willkommen zurück Presseclub
nachgefragt im Netz bei Phoenix und bei
WDR 5 ich nehme eine Frage aus dem Netz
vorweg das ist eine ja Nein Frage müssen
die Subventionen Beispiel für die
Fabriken eigentlich zurückgezahlt werden
nein
okay dann gehen wir nach
Solingen zu Rüdiger Bäume Herr Bäume
willkommen im Presseclub ja schönen
guten Mittag guten Tag
meine Frage wir hatten in den 90er
Jahren schon mal eine Firma die hieß
Eriksson und die haben Handys produziert
die haben alle Subventionen abgegriffen
haben ihr Werk aufgebaut und als die
Mindestlaufzeit rum war haben sie alles
schnell wieder zugemacht waren weg so
wie können wir verhindern dass wenn wir
Milliarden und einmal Milliarden für
einen neuen Chip-Hersteller ausgeben
dass der nicht nach kürzester Zeit oder
nach irgendwelchen Mindestlaufzeiten
sagt danke schön ich habe kassiert ich
mag nicht von den hätten sie gerne
Antwort
das ist egal in die Runde okay dann
gucke ich einfach also ich habe es
angeschlossen wir haben für heute
angesprochen wir brauchen Verträge wir
brauchen mindestverträge mindestens zehn
Jahre und eventueller
Rückzahlungspflicht ich weiß so was ich
schwer verhandelbar sie sprechen
natürlich für den Sündenfall in Bochum
damals wo wir irrsinnige Gelder
reingesteckt haben und die ganze
Handyproduktion abgezogen ist es geht
nur über Verträge aber es wird dann
schwieriger die Unternehmen anzusehen
okay okay ganz kurz Ergänzung genau
darum geht's und natürlich muss man ein
gewisses Umfeld schaffen wo es dann auch
nicht mehr so einfach ist zu sagen ich
gehe jetzt mal also aber das ist die
Hauptsache gute Verträge ja interessant
Herr Bäume wichtiger Punkt und
eigentlich Selbstverständlichkeiten
denkt man aber
vielleicht gibt's Kollegin Kollegen in
den Redaktionen die da noch mal genauer
nachgucken und nachfragen was da jetzt
passiert danke und tschüss nach Solingen
wir sind in Senftenberg bei Kerstin
weitner willkommen versenden Frau
weitner
hallo in die Runde sehr schönes Thema
interessant
ja Entschuldigung jetzt habe ich
bestimmt rein eingequatscht
Entschuldigung sind dran wir hören Ihnen
zu und schießen sie los mit ihrer
Beobachtung oder Frage genau also ich
würde den Titel sogar ganz anders nennen
ist unsere Wirtschaft nicht in Burnout
und zwar deshalb wir stellen uns hier in
den kleineren Städten immer die Frage
warum junge Leute nicht in Mittelstand
und kleinen
Wirtschaft investieren warum wir hier
für gute Firmen keine Nachfolger finden
und und und und auch für Geschäfte keine
Nachfolger finden Einzelhandel und und
und und stellen immer wieder fest dass
wir zu hören kriegen unter diesen
Bedingungen nein Danke
dass zu viel
knebel-vorschriften sind zu viel
[Musik]
naja wenig Möglichkeiten auch an Geld zu
kommen muss ich auch dazu sagen ohne
dass man sich dermaßen verschuldet
also es ist sehr unattraktiv geworden
für mich ist es auch so was ich immer
wieder höre und und Burnout auch deshalb
da gehe ich auf die Arbeitskräfte viele
der die jetzt im Arbeitsprozess stehen
sind ausgelaugt sind fertig haben gar
keinen Geist mehr für neue
Innovationen entschuldigung ich bin
aufgeregt Innovationen
freuen sich wenn sie überhaupt noch das
Rentenalter erreichen deswegen war nicht
immer davor mit Anhebung des
Rentenalters wer wirklich aktiv im
Arbeitsleben steht das froh wenn er mit
63 gibt ja sowieso nicht mehr ist ja
schon mit Aufschlägen will
bedacht meine Generation Baujahr 63 darf
ja gar nicht mehr mit 63 in Rente gehen
ohne Abzüge das gehört auch zur Wahrheit
also für mich ist es so dass wir kaum
Bedingungen haben die jungen Leuten hier
wirklich noch leicht noch oder überhaupt
möglich macht zu investieren und wenn
wir dann gute unter junge Unternehmen
haben gehen sie eben Kaufland und hier
die Frage warum was machen wir falsch
intensiv falsch und ich finde die
Subvention für das Chip wie die
chip-fabrik auch zu hoch und ich weiß
auch dass im mittelständischen
Unternehmen hier wieder sagen und wo
bleiben wir
vielen Dank sie haben viele beobachten
mit uns geteilt danke dafür zum Teil
sind einfach
diskussionsbeobachtungen die wir gar
nicht diskutieren müssen aber im Kern
fange ich mal mit der oder nein ich
würde auf die erste Frage in der Runde
einfach mal gucken was nicht versteht
sie haben sie eine Antwort auf diese
erste Frage wo sind die Nachfolger wo
ist die Lust was weiter zu machen ich
glaube das ist ein großes Problem ist
das eine ist tatsächlich eine
Infrastruktur wenn sie in Senftenberg
leben dann haben sie nebenan
Schwarzheide da ist BASF und dann ist
weit herum nichts ja und das ist das
Hauptproblem deswegen ich immer dafür
plädiere und die Unterstützung gut
finden weil ich glaube das ist nicht
anders geht wenn in Schwarzheide das
Licht ausgeht dann ist Feierabend in der
Region auf der anderen Seite natürlich
darf man nicht den großen Konzern alles
nur in den Rachen werfen aber das andere
was ich viel interessanter finde ist das
was Sie angesprochen haben was die
Bedingungen für junge Unternehmen angeht
für Start-ups da sind wir wieder beim
schnellen Internet ja wenn ich wo soll
ich da was machen wenn ich gar keine
Verbindung in die Welt habe also sind so
kleine Dinge über die wir seit Jahren
reden und das ist das was mich stört und
ich glaube dass man wirklich da
tatsächlich mal was strukturelles machen
muss um auch ein bisschen Lust zu machen
auch ins ländliche zu gehen damit die
Stadt Land Gefälle das auch nicht gut
ist für unsere Wirtschaft also sie haben
das richtige angesprochen und natürlich
da muss der muss der Staat drauf
reagieren danke Frau Weidner für ihre
Impulse Gruß nach Senftenberg wir
springen ein bisschen nach Süden nach
Dresden zu Thomas Schiller guten Tag
Herr Schiller was geht Ihnen durch den
Kopf ja guten Tag in die Runde es geht
mir eigentlich um in die Kerbe zu
schlagen die wir gerade gehört haben um
Bürokratieabbau und die Verringerung des
administrativen auffangens Deutschland
zumindestens Westdeutschland ist durch
den Mittelstand stark geworden und das
sind kleine Unternehmen wo man
vielleicht ein Geschäftsführer mit
vielleicht einen ruhigen erweiterten
assistenzsatz denn die alle Dinge die
Sie beachten müssen aber arbeiten kommen
sie kam noch dazu ja eigentlich das
Geschäft zu machen und wir haben die
ganze Zeit jetzt über große Pension das
für uns wieder gehört da würde ich jetzt
auch nicht unbedingt darüber sprechen
wollen aber
kann man nicht einfach mal sagen ähnlich
wie in der Corona für mich die niemals
für ein paar Jahre gewisse Gesetze und
ich stellen die einfach mal außer Kraft
um zu sagen auch in den mindset der
Verwaltungen dort sitzen Juristen
juristisch geprägte Menschen
machen alles ganz genau das ist auch
schön für Deutschland aber am Ende des
Tages behindert das nur wie gesagt mein
Punkt ist die Management attention von
kleinen Unternehmen ist nicht
ausreichend um sowohl Geschäft zu machen
als auch den bürokratischen Überbau in
Deutschland nicht mittlerweile
entwickelt hat Abteilung Großunternehmen
ist ein ganz anderes Sache und deswegen
wie gesagt einfach mal wirklich
entschlacken und im Zweifelsfall auch
mal sagen für vier fünf Jahre gewisse
Zeit wo die Gesetze halt nicht wirklich
durchgedrückt werden um einfach mal
loszustoßen dann kann man ja gucken was
schief gelaufen ist und das wird danke
ich finde den Gedanken erstmal sehr
verlockend zu sagen bevor wir
grundsätzlich diskutieren machen wir mal
eine Pause für zwei drei vier Jahre und
lassen Vorschrift mal außer acht ja nein
also ist auf jeden Fall ein ein sehr
sinnvoller Vorschlag es müsste halt
jemand anpacken und wie schwer wir uns
damit tun das sehen wir zum Beispiel
gerade auch im Bereich der Bauwirtschaft
das ist ganz interessant dass für den
Bau von flüchtlingsunterkünften wurden
jetzt tatsächlich die Regeln gelockert
dass man schneller Unterkünfte bauen
kann und da stellt sich natürlich die
Frage wenn wir so ein großes
Wohnungsproblem haben vor allem in den
Ballungszentren warum macht man das
nicht für Wohnungsneubau insgesamt aber
dann kommen natürlich wieder all
diejenigen die im Lauf der vergangenen
Jahrzehnte diese Regeln entwickelt haben
deren Job es ist sie auch zu überprüfen
dass sie eingehalten werden und sagen
Uni auf keinen Fall und das also alles
ganz gefährlich auch wenn andere Länder
mit deutlich weniger Regeln auskommen
als wir also das ist ich glaube das
Problem ist auch so ein bisschen
Deutschland ist in der alternde
Gesellschaft uns fehlt zuweilen auch
einfach den Mut mal ins Risiko zu gehen
und wenn wir uns als Gesellschaft darauf
einigen könnten da mehr zu wagen ich
werde dabei danke ich glaube das ist ein
ganz wichtiger Impuls und an der Stelle
brauchen wir auch eine öffentliche
Debatte ne also wie kommen wir da ins
Tun und reden nicht endlos um den heißen
Brei herum Gruß nach Dresden jetzt sind
wir in Altenburg in Thüringen Bolko
Johannes Köpke willkommen willkommen
hallo Herr Schönborn hallo Herr Köpke
also ich habe jetzt hier eine Sache
nicht ganz richtig verstanden also ich
habe jetzt zum ersten Mal diese
Statistik gesehen
in der hervor aus der hervorgeht im
Grunde genommen dass also wenn ich es
richtig verstanden habe dass deutsche
Investoren 130 Milliarden im Ausland
investieren sie nochmal ja genau während
ausländische Investoren in Deutschland
ungefähr 10,5 Milliarden investieren das
ist ja im Grunde genommen nicht mal ein
Zehntel wenn ich jetzt richtig
verstanden habe
dann würde das ja im Grunde genommen
bedeuten dass Deutschland im Ausland
jede Menge Arbeitsplätze schafft
während sozusagen ausländische
Investoren in Deutschland relativ wenige
es sind 135 Milliarden ja
da frage ich mich jetzt zum Beispiel
also die Frage die Stichwort außer
Outsourcing da frage ich mich jetzt im
Grunde genommen ich meine was macht das
mit unserem Arbeitsmarkt
während ich meine wenn Deutschland jede
Menge Arbeitsplätze im Ausland
produziert während aber sozusagen davon
relativ wenig zurückkommt dann sozusagen
verstehe ich das nicht ganz richtig also
ich habe das jetzt zum ersten Mal
gesehen diese Statistik aber
also ich darf da sehe ich den Grund
dafür nicht okay und ihren Gedanken gut
nachvollziehen und gucke mal
ich würde gerne mal sagen das vielleicht
eine ganz wichtige Botschaft bezüglich
der Frage wo wir stehen das santerweise
hat sich der Arbeitsmarkt in der letzten
Zeit und die künftiger Zeit wird sich
der relativ positiv entwickeln wer also
alle die erwarten jetzt dass wir eine
Massenarbeitslosigkeit kriegen völlig
daneben das ist Phänomen dass wir es
hingekriegt haben das hat was mit
Fachkräftemangel zu tun die Nachfrage
nach Arbeits relativ hoch also wir haben
zurzeit das Problem nicht wir haben das
Problem mit ökologischen Umbau natürlich
das Arbeitsplätze gewechselt werden
müssen deswegen hier nicht beantworten
und das zweite ist bei den
Direktinvestitionen deutsche Unternehmen
ins Ausland führt es nicht sozusagen
unmittelbar sondern Arbeitsplatz
Vernichtung das ist eine wichtige
Aussage sondern sind zu wechseln das
also wenn bei BASF wenn wenn die oder
jetzt batteriewerk dann ist es kein
Abbau eines Arbeitsplatz und ist
Verzicht was nicht ganz stimmt in
Deutschland weil VW auch in
Wilhelmshaven investiert aber es ist ein
Verzicht auf zusätzliche Arbeitsplätze
also so kann man ihre These erklären
zusätzliche Arbeitsplätze die eine in
Deutschland hätten geschaffen werden
können die gehen ins Ausland da ist
natürlich ein Problem auf die Dauer
man kann ergänzen dass natürlich
nichtsdestotrotz die Attraktivität im
Ausland zu investieren schon ein
bisschen höher ist viele Unternehmen
momentan und dass wir als Eltern der
Gesellschaft sogar ein Interesse an
Auslandsinvestitionen haben könnten weil
irgendjemand muss ja dann unsere Renten
bezahlen und das passiert natürlich auch
durch Anlagen im Ausland okay so dass in
Wolfsburg sozusagen Gewinn versteuert
wird der in South Carolina erarbeitet
wird Herr Köpke ein weites Feld ich
hoffe zumindest ein bisschen konnten wir
erklären
also aber was ich jetzt nicht ganz
verstanden habe ich meine diese Leute
sozusagen wieder ich meine die die
sozusagen die Arbeitnehmer die gehen ja
dann nicht mit mit diesen Investitionen
und arbeiten da weiter im Ausland oder
ja jetzt haben wir jetzt haben wir
natürlich einen Mangel an Arbeitnehmern
in Deutschland also insofern fällt das
sozusagen nicht so auf ne schwieriger
wäre es wenn wir auch genug Fachkräfte
hätten und es dann keine
investitionsfaktor USA klagt darüber
wird geklagt dass sie die Fahrt
qualifizierten Fachkräfte für die
deutschen Unternehmen die dort ansiedeln
gar nicht haben gegen Problem ich sage
Danke ich gehe weiter lässt sich nicht
vollständig aufklären aber
danke danke für die kluge Beobachtung in
Hamm Westfalen ist Matthias Leffers bei
uns erfasst guten Tag ich hätte Marco
ökonomische Frage an Herrn Heckel und
eine kleine Analyse noch wir haben
weltweit das Phänomen dass die
Unternehmen nettosparer sind das heißt
von erfolgswirtschaftlichen
Gesamtrechnungen muss ich immer einen
Sektor gesamtwirtschaftlich Verschulden
das ist zwingend logisch und in den USA
also so wir haben Leistung für Land wie
viel Titel haben es in den letzten
Jahren und die Unternehmen sind auch
heute Nord dort netto Sparer das heißt
dort muss ich zwingend der Staat
verschulden und meine Frage ist wie
lösen wir das in Deutschland weil hier
wird jetzt der Staat bald wieder nicht
so Sparer durch die Aktion von Herr
Lindner und hier sind die Unternehmen
natürlich auch weiter netto-fahrer und
das ist ein massives Problem weil mit
den Schulden steigen auch die
Geldvermögen das ist nicht das Problem
aber wir müssen ja unseren Kapital
stocken das ist ja das was wir verändern
müssen und das ist das was wir unseren
Kindern vererben den schlechten oder
guten Kapital Stock nicht die Schulden
und die Vermögen und das würde ich gerne
mal wissen wie er Ekel das aussieht
unter dem Aspekt dass der Monetarismus
also bezüglich Geld drucken das ist auch
nicht mehr kapieren aber das würde ich
immer von der Ecke wissen danke
auch ich habe Maschinenbau und
Geldtheorie und makrokonomie darf ich
mir nicht vor dass ich nicht ganz folgen
kann aber er häkelt sehr gut verstanden
leider ist diese wunderbare Sendung
nicht dazu geeint jetzt ein Festvortrag
zu halten zum Thema was ich gerne täte
ich kann ich will das übersetzen was ich
sagen und da ist ein strukturelles
Problem haben sie völlig Recht die
deutsche Wirtschaft die
unternehmenswirtschaft vor allem die
Industrie im über längere Zeitraum
betrachtet benutzt die Gewinne die sie
macht weniger zum reinvestieren also
neue Investitionen sondern sie benutzt
sie im selber um die Kapitalmärkte zu
gehen das ist ein Problem dabei will es
belassen das ist ein Unterschied zu USA
also im Grunde genommen kann man von
Unternehmen wenn man den Forderung draus
machen wollte weil sie jetzt mal locker
mache selbst zu sagen die Unternehmen
müssten eigentlich mehr von dem was ihr
gewinnen einnehmen auch investieren an
Sachen Investitionen danke schön danke
schön jetzt versteht wir haben noch 45
Sekunden 15 davon für die Frage und 30
für Sie für die
fragt warum wird neuindustrie nur im
Osten angesiedelt das
bevölkerungsverhältnis ist doch West 67
Millionen zuerst 18 Millionen weil wir
immer noch Nachholbedarf haben und weil
wir diese Strukturen nicht haben
einfaches Beispiel habe ich eben mit
Schwarzheide gesagt wenn im Ruhrgebiet
eine Firma pleite geht dann haben Sie
als Arbeitnehmer die Chance irgendwo in
100 km sich zumindest zu bewerben wenn
spät an der oder die Raffinerie pleite
ist dann war es das dann hat der
Fußballclub kein Sponsor mehr und dann
geht dort in einer ganzen Region das
Licht aus deswegen ist es immer noch ein
Problem und deswegen müssen wir immer
noch darüber reden ich glaube im
Ruhrgebiet reichen auch 20
je nachdem wo man es bedanke mich sehr
herzlich Danke an sie und einen
wunderbaren Sonntag Gruß aus Köln alles
Gute lassen sie uns gut reden